sa clique manque actuellement
à l'arrière derrière le truc vert la
côte d'ivoire la bobine qui enroule le
ch allure du bugaled breizh chalutier
breton de 24 mètres qui en quelques
secondes a sombré au large de
l'angleterre le 15 janvier 2004 il ne
reste qu'un tas de ferraille 18 ans plus
tard les hommes continuent d'entourer la
faire et pour thierry le métayer qui a
perdu son père lors du naufrage
l'émotion reste vive à la vision de
l'épave quand les dix ans l'anniversaire
du naufrage
les militaires ont accepté que trois
personnes rentrent déposé une gerbe
ferai ma femme et mes deux filles et moi
makita la dri
avec tout un parterre de
militaires elle avait 6 ans elle à dire
maman qu'est ce qu'ils veulent arriver
au bateau l'avez jamais vu évidemment et
le jour du drame dont le périmètre de
navigation du chalutier des sous marins
participent à un exercice militaire de
l'otan moins d'une heure après le
naufrage d'un bâtiment néerlandais le
dolphin fait surface et fait inhabituel
participent aux opérations de sauvetage
rapidement le submersible est suspecté
d'être impliqué dans l'accident mais en
juin 2016 malgré les témoignages à
charge amsterdam rejette amèrement les
accusations et la justice française
préfère déclarer un non lieu plutôt que
de mettre en cause de sous marins en
fait les conclusions de la cour d'appel
et la cour de cass et de dire on n'est
pas
comme on peut pas dire à 100% que c'est
un sous-marin puisqu'on n'a pas son nom
personne ne s'est dénoncé il n'y a pas
de preuve et c'est même s'il ya des
lourds indices sur plusieurs sous-marins
et plusieurs marines eh bien on va
laisser ouverte une porte entre une
croche molle et un naufrage comment dire
entrée est comment dire commis par un
sous-marin donc cette crouch molle qui
vient dire on peut pas dire que c'est un
sous marin alors qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution il y aura une autre solution
c'est un énorme une énorme baleine mais
sinon pour descendre un chalutier de 24
mètres en 37 secondes au fond s'il n'a
pas été tirées il est impossible qu'ils
descendent aussi vite tout seul
l'enquêté relancée à londres en 2020
après notamment la découverte de deux
corps repêchés en mer près de l'endroit
où le chalutier a sombré à partir
d'aujourd'hui et pendant trois semaines
d'audience la haute cour de londres va
entendre une quarantaine de témoignages
marin secouriste expert maritime ou
encore militaire objectif revenir sur
toutes les incohérences de l'enquète et
tenter d'expliquer les circonstances du
drame et après 18 ans de procédure
judiciaire qui n'ont pas permis
d'élucider la sphère les familles place
énormément d'espoir dans cette nouvelle
enquête en se battant comme ça pendant
18 ans j'en suis sûr fondamentalement
que en face les gens qui sont pas des
enfants de choeur qui font un boulot où
ils sont capables de mentir on sait les
eaux 10 quand même est-ce que un petit
mensonge à la base ça peut être alors ça
aurait pu être réglée assez facilement
avec les familles 18 ans dans le merde
où on passe parfois pour des menteurs ou
plus personne ne croit nos déclarations
que la mer est
rouge et le soleil et bleu est bien est
ce que la prochaine fois on faire
autrement et surtout est-ce qu'on n'est
pas un peu plus prudent lorsqu'on fait
des exercices en situation réelle et
qu'il ya des chalutiers où des cargos
qui travaillent à côté thierry le
métayer ainsi que tous les membres des
familles des victimes vont être invités
à s'exprimer dès aujourd'hui pour
défendre leurs hypothèses et tenter
d'obtenir les réponses qu'ils attendent
depuis si longtemps